[Musique]
c'est ça
bien pratique
je
les mots
[Musique]
les séries
je la montre
le croiser
c'est
encore là
quelque chose qui va payer
on
[Musique]
maj
des enfants des gens
il ya reçu
voilà
quand je vais pas
je ne peux
le style
famille
message 85
l'étoile a rappelé
pour consommer
non
les versions
10h40
[Musique]
ça finit plus d'éclater
est vrai il faudrait que nous
la perte
tout savoir
ça
[Musique]
bolduc
malema
collège de quartier à banon ses côtés
ankara
rochât
à
[Musique]
comment
jean françois kahn
[Musique]
lyon paris
gratuit
joli
aurait-on
[Musique]
avec lui
comment faire
[Musique]
tél
je vais passer
la fatigue
[Musique]
c'est par là
le haut
[Musique]
lamy
le plus
[Musique]
vous
hop
[Musique]
une fois par an
je
[Musique]
djediat la main
mais comment est-il
en
ça va
tu parles
et
m
[Musique]
et
l'apport des fêtes
[Musique]
m
bien
[Musique]
fabien didier
il baptise il a monté une affaire
il
il ya par ici
non mais
j'ai pas vu là c'est bon c'est bon
s
suite à dix ans a cédé 2
le premier ministre vous êtes attachés
nous avons pris
section
on continue mais c'est vrai
nous sommes aussi heureux d'aider
hospitalier parce qu'il manque du
personnel
on le dit depuis des années un manque de
moyens et on comprend que aujourd'hui
sur pc on est tous nient tout fonctionne
et on ne veut pas de kobe tu à la fois
les personnes
l'analyse et le referee une forme d'art
et d'histoire
alors il y aurait une bonne nouvelle
quand même c'est que le préfet n'a pas
encore sorti le décret il faut 24 heures
pour sa mise en application
donc les restaurants pourront rester
ouverts jusqu'à samedi minuit donc là le
week-end n'est pas complètement du
samedi soir
c'est à dire que le service de 5 devrait
pouvoir avoir lieu de façon à pouvoir
permettre aux restaurateurs d'écouler
toute la marchandise qui a été acheté
pour ce week-end c'est un moindre mal je
le sais président mais c'est pas ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on respecte leur reste
juste marié évidemment
autre action en justice moi j'ai prévu
rassure moi là
parce que le pré c'est l'intérêt du jeu
à s'apprêter à dire ces halles
aujourd'hui aux restaurateurs qui selon
halim le commerce
le président s'il est là de façon à
remettre symboliquement l'ensemble dépôt
de bilan de la profession va venir à
venir montrer c'est une bonne chose de
les déconnecter du terrain
[Applaudissements]
eh oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nous allons prendre de façon
symbolique
tous les bilans des restaurateurs ils
sont change dans la mesure nous allons
déposer le bilan devant le tribunal de
commerce on va fermer les entreprises
adhérentes en tant qu'écrivain petit
conciliation ne veut pas dire qu'on part
en liquidation une fois la moitié en
france
mais la pauvreté
l'intérêt général dans le monde
économique
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi
m
on va décrocher de façon symbolique le
bilan de tous les restaurateurs on l
iphone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
vous pouvez le poste chez les
restaurateurs les hôteliers les
cafetiers ne sont pas seuls le monde
politique les accompagnent il ne
supporte pas ce qu'on nous la fermeture
de nos bars et nos restaurants
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous avons
développé un front commun
nous avons écrit une lettre commune au
premier ministre lui paie la chambre de
commerce ou le lendemain pour les
remarques et j'ai oublié quelques mm à
chocolat mais je les dis la chambre
commerciale à jean luc chauvin guettait
de cautionner la cpmc obligations se
promettant je me rase et pme
la gr 10 des artistes les artisans un
fait tout le monde l'économie de marché
le champ de département et de sa
métropole sont là puissent tous les
sanitaires je vous invite à créer les
conditions de nouveaux jeunes de plus en
plus je sais que les syndicats de
salariés sont là aussi et qui nous avons
pas dans ce comportement parce que s'il
devait y avoir la fermeture des
restaurants des bars et des hôtels
les salariés seraient aussi mal que nous
nous sommes donc il est clair que ces
deux ce jour que pour la révolte
marseillaise pour s'opposer aux
comportements qui nous sont imposées par
ce gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certaines mesures habituelles mais je
vous le dis c'est le premier jour d'un
premier comportement
cet après midi nous allons faire des
rencontres avec le ministre délégué à je
ne sais quoi
et oui mais j'ai des difficultés
il est clair que cet après midi il va y
avoir des ministres ministériel dans
marseille
et avez vous avez vous dessinez renault
travaille sur des signes récents de la
manière de se comporter parce qu'il ya
deux rendez-vous dans après-midi bien
sûr que des élus lui et le monde
économique sera reçu pour me suffisait
en préfecture je le pense et que nous
vivons une provocation avec un ministre
de l'ict 2 de la santé
ils ont fait un ministre de la santé
on veut nouveau leur chance j'étais
moyen terme ministre de la santé
il ya pris des décisions à
l'emporte-pièce et qui a demandé un
préfet de vouziers grand défi qui n'est
pas encore paru nous ne savons pas
quelle heure nous fermons ça veut dire
que parce que nos fermes gens ici donc
on va rester l'assemblée de la parole à
tous les gentils manteau parce qu'ils
ont des choses à vous dire c'est que le
début nous sommes venus ici parce que
j'imagine bien que le choix du tribunal
de commerce défend les choix au hasard
nous savons tous que si nous avions des
problématiques de dépôt de bilan c'est
ici que les for you eh bien ça
sous-entend que sont déjà là pour leur
dire que peut-être nous viendrons des
consignes mobile ou que les conditions
nous mettre tout ce temps que nous
sommes en protection pénible de ma mère
j'ai abîmé près des côtes et on va se
parler tranquillement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
il me manque
inquiétez pas fauté sur 20
[Musique]
attaque allemande
bon
les modules
[Musique]
attentif
un acte comme une audi tt
il
19h10
vous voulez dire
à l'avenir on est
[Musique]
pour
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
d'accord
oh
je
non
[Musique]
on
reste à leila le reste
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
je crois que ça passe
ça
d
[Musique]
ça me découvrir
pour
parmi eux
c'est quand même le toit
miracle
oui je
la voiture
[Musique]
le faire
m
ouais
[Musique]
ça m'a réveillé
travailler aujourd'hui
à
pacifique
je voudrais
loin de là
[Musique]
j'étais folle
les monoplaces
décider si les vingt sept ans
[Musique]
voyage le président
brad en inde
j'ai mis en jeu
regarde
une
[Musique]
non
les consoles sont
on est prêt
habitant
[Musique]
m
papa
reste
entretien
acteur
[Musique]
il
maintenant toi
[Musique]
là
le monde
[Musique]
m
vous permettront éventuellement le test
[Rires]
dieu merci à tous fini le plan final de
mise la distanciation les masques
nous sortons du tribunal de commerce
nous avons rencontré la vice-présidente
reprochez-vous
voilà je peux pas faire mieux nous avons
rencontré la présidence de la chambre 2
tribunal de commerce pardo qui nous a
assurés de son soutien
c'est bien mais ça suffira fin il est
clair un moment donné alors écoutez moi
s'il vous plaît il est clair un moment
donné je ne peux pas dire que l'as rome
et le match et on
[Applaudissements]
l'école non mais il faut pas les
soutenir on les soutient j'étais au
début juillet chez lui et il m'a faut
aussi je t'assure
voilà tusk qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on
fasse comme la ville noah s'est offert
dix mois s'il faut faire alors pour sept
rames
moi je travaille tant pis pour toi si tu
ne sais pas je t'expliquerai le poème
particulier et qu'est ce que tu veux que
je fasse et super ministre et cause de
moi alors groupe vous pouvez assister
[Musique]
on assiste à ce qui se passe dans mars
et c'est à dire le désespoir bon à ce
qu'il arrive catane ou ferme canton de
jumilhac atteint aujourd'hui et c'est
pas parce que c'est pas parce que notre
amitié que ben ça m'impressionne par
tous je suis à ses côtés et je partage à
1000 peut penser à mon avis si vous êtes
là aujourd'hui c'est parce que lumière
puis la décision de quitter condition de
se réunir laissez pas parler
laissez moi parler
[Musique]
la première manifestation qu'a lieu la
leur initiative de vie et l'avenue tombe
c'est le début mais je n'oublie personne
ni les du scrutin ni les bars de nuit ni
ribordy les cafés et les restaurants et
les hôtels
je n'oublie personne évidemment on avait
plus personne
y à l'automne toutes les entreprises
concernées goûter les enfants mon voyage
organisé pour y arriver ou que l'on peut
faire et coface ne pour n'importe quoi
je n'oublie personne
jeudi sur tous les médias je dis à tous
les ministères jeudi chez tous les
préfets de notre métier c'est une
filière complète qui peut tuer tout le
monde
non
[Musique]
à l'écouter
[Applaudissements]
oh
bonjour reposant sur gimone à 14h30 le
ministre inversera la timone
attentes et aux blessés par les cylons
fear 3 mois je vous prends pas ce père
non d'aller devant le lâcher à 14h30
aujourd'hui vont râler filles et restos
ouverts soyez tous
je ne peux leur manteau que j'ai peur je
maintiens d'inverser la vapeur studio
revient pour nous défaire voilà ce que
je me suis gay mais vous êtes touchant
et on va visiter un centre la première
c'est quoi nous prenons futur merci
[Applaudissements]
encore là c'est important mans depuis le
début je les dis et je comprends la
colère des commerçants je comprends la
colère des professionnels
voilà on les a poussés à bout dès
aujourd'hui sont là il montre les
horizons
on est à aujourd'hui à
tous unis pour dire tous les secrets
commandes
[Applaudissements]
on est là en soutien et d'entretien des
restaurateurs il faut que l'état nous
écoutons peut pas on peut pas sacrifier
des pans entiers de l'économie
aujourd'hui vous avez entendu un cri de
désespoir de ces personnes oui il ya des
moyens on a été en avance sur ce virus
pendant toute la gestion de la crise
pour nous écoutent le monde travaille
ensemble
les restaurateurs les bars ils sont là
vont respecter les distanciation vont
respecter les protections oui nous faut
des moyens et nous faut des moyens dans
les hôpitaux il nous faut des moyens
dans la police donc s'ils voulaient au
niveau du gouvernement le ministre et sa
famille dit qu'il entend de lotfi du
coeur de l'ensemble des personnes qui
sont là c'est pareil non ce n'est pas
qu'on ne veut pas l'insurrection aurait
simplement pour nous écoute on veut en
finir avec cet article manoeuvre pour
négocier mais celle aujourd'hui je les
ai perdus un an du terme à sport day qui
seraient attachées sur ces territoires
on est attaché à nos habitants on veut
les protéger on veut en finir avec
sérieuse mais malheureusement ce virus
il est là il faut qu'on fasse avec la
bulle très bien pour ça il faut que le
gouvernement soit à nos côtés
qu'on soit tous ensemble on de pas de
fronde on veut pas être révolution on
veut pas être les uns contre les autres
on veut se débarrasser de ce véhicule
mais pour ça il faut que chacun prenne
ce risque
nous nous sommes là pour appliquer la
loi il faut que cette loi soit de bon
sens ciel ans aujourd'hui on sait quand
est ce que les bars vont fermer
finalement où c'est encore le flou le
ministre bien cet après midi je pense
qu'il donnera sa décision définitive
dans la pétition on va pas fermer avant
restaurèrent messieurs on a des enfants
à nourrir les voies séparées s'extraire
après marseille pourquoi est ce que vous
êtes
je suis venue manifester par rapport à
nos brasseries dom com - l'accord et je
comprends pas pourquoi les parisiens
aujourd'hui zone à rien après marseille
voila c est pire que le football je
cours je comprend pas exactement mais
chez nous ça se passe très bien on garde
le protocole de distances de sécurité
les masses qui sont exigées donc il ya
déjà les droits le colis il ya tout ce
qui est bon est ce qu'on prend pas soin
du jour au lendemain
ce ministre est venu fermer comme chez
moi on n'a pas été avertie du tout donc
on a été averti et par le site internet
et d'après les informations